hello whoa wait hello sorry there's no
transition Ben apologies that's it's
okay that's a tradition at this point I
think uh hey everybody I can't see the
chat Ben you can see the chat right yeah
I'm I'm gonna be basically sitting here
reading what everyone says
cool highly Fridays everybody how's it
going we're uh as I'm sure you can tell
from pretty much everybody on the
Internet
we're streaming from home because we've
we've been we've been asked to stay home
in these these trying times but don't
worry mean been figured out how to
stream so that we can still do community
Fridays with all of you
exactly a lot a lot of intense crazy
weird rewiring and work gianluca's done
so somehow make this stream work with
both of our cameras up in the game and
anything same setup we have at the
office we're just in different parts of
the county so yeah so yeah so if the
point of this stream is that we're gonna
play doom Eternals battle mode and we
want to check it out we wanna check it
out with you so if you guys want to play
with us we have the instructions below
basically if you just joined GameSpot's
official steam group you can join the
here if I pull it up you join the group
chap and then you will click on me and
be like hey I want I want to join I want
to join played with John Luke and then
you can you can play with us if no one
is in or people are setting up right now
we could just pop it and play a little
just like random like custom matches or
whatever against randos yeah is there
anyone in the chat who's who's in a play
or should I just hop in just to get it
going
maybe just one day kind of to warm it up
sir
well it's a I'm still I'm still amazed
and surprised by what Shawn Lucas
managed to put together so I've played
this twice III was playing earlier this
morning and I got both times I was the
Slayer hey I'm still the Slayer okay
first time I lost horribly second time
was a really fun back-and-forth where I
won so I'm well not enough players what
all the players were there though let's
try again
got scared it's also launch day for the
game so I'm sure there's issues also I'm
sure a lot of people are just playing
the single-player yeah there's lots of
rip and tear through there but yeah
we've we've both played through this
game all the way already we've we've
seen we've seen doom and it is good I
see a lot of people talking about Animal
Crossing
Brandon Hernandez included are wonderful
always here pal so I think I saw if Bob
Jones also got Animal Crossing that I'm
doing for ya I've been playing them
across from this morning I've been
having a blast
oh yeah it's it's so good I feel very
fortunate that I was one of the people
in the office that got doom early
because it means that I was able to get
it out of the way so that I could focus
on just Animal Crossing big same it was
actually a really big worry of mine and
I wouldn't know how to like split my
time up mm-hmm
but at the same time Animal Crossing is
sort of designed in a way where you
can't just keep playing it like you kind
of hit your limit of like well this is
all I can do for the day right in which
case then that's when you switch over to
doom right yeah also do
I'm not sure why I feel like every time
I test this set up it works perfectly
and then every time I actually like do
something live with it it kind of freaks
out yes it's a lot a lot of fun just
testing and moving things around as I
sit here - just yeah by the way this is
my first time playing a demon so
apologies I probably thank you will do
this badly I really like the idea for
this multiplayer mode though I like that
guy's rainbow name
pakia that's uh excuse me some like old
old like just enemy territory everyone
would do it all time oh yeah yes I like
immediately died I tried playing the
tutorial and then it like glitched out
on me and I had to like quit up a game
it was it was kind of weird huh yeah
I've also had because I finally got the
chance to play it on PC and dealing with
some of the weird stuff with that like
apparently the overlay can cause a lot
of FPS issues and that was a problem I
had right okay between my different
things but I don't know how to activate
them up there we go
there you go I guess I'd probably the
grenade button okay let's give me some
health and let's get a yep there we go
okay we got it now we're figuring it out
whoa
my terms are I've beaten this doom game
uh one and a half at this point me yeah
I would say same like I've beaten it
once and then I've gone back and played
enough for like capture and stuff that
I've probably played it like one and a
half oh that's gone can't cats making
noises oh it's cute yeah that kind here
more cats and stream for some reason
it's my favorite part about everybody
streaming from home yeah I guess you
pets
oh yeah see cats
that's what there's your fur this is the
big upside to having to work from home
all the time as I get to deal with a cat
he just kind of like hangs out but okay
we got him and by we I mean the other
guy because I feel I got into anything
yeah I can't really confused he's like
what is going on what does that cat's
name so his his his actual name that his
parents gave him his boo boy I call him
Albert whisker because that was the name
that they promised they'd call him and
they never did it then commit but it's
okay though because they the actually
name the other cat we have which isn't
even in the room his name is actually
Leon so I guess I run around like Ashley
Ashley Graham yelling Leon all the time
Leon that's a lot of yeah the cats on
deck just playing with a cardboard box
right now I hope you had more
traditional multiplayer later on I I'd
be interested to see what they're
planning on doing excited I think that
the they've got like a season pass
already lined up with it campaign
experience yes they said two campaign
expansions so seems like they might be
focusing a lot on single-player stuff
which is pretty cool yeah okay yeah that
the multiplayer was actually kind of fun
in 2016
knocker why all I got him yeah oh there
we go
so you said to kind of break in a bit
yeah
yeah I'm getting it I'm figuring that's
kinda how I felt with my earlier matches
like it this game has a little bit of a
learning curve where you're just sitting
there kind of trying to figure things
out but once you would you get it once
to get it it feels pretty good
just mess him up there my my favorite my
favorite comment from Brandon coming and
talk about how great the podcast was oh
thank you thank you Brian I'm Brendan
thank you for listening I'm so sorry my
microphone decided to break I hope that
turned out okay Jake was the one who
edited that and I had a chance to listen
so I hope that sounded ok it was a
chance to listen the whole thing yet but
it's it's still kind of cool to see how
we're getting all this stuff sorted out
for like recording video from home
yeah smokey has a point this is doom
eternal yeah this is doom eternal you're
not wrong
it's not fortnight it's not whatever
else play it is doom eternal which is
out today well we found the housing so
you can't carry the whole team no you
got you got to work sound a parent of
hell oh that sounds fun kind of hard to
hear you a little bit but the podcast
was all good - either way cool long as
all came through as long as it all came
through they let me back on next week
I'll make sure it's fixed
see what other kind of side I kind of
like I've got a chance to play much of
this multiplayer mode but I like the
idea that it plays a lot into light
I guess what Doom is it it reminds me a
lot of that Assassin's Creed multiplayer
mode that me and you talk about a lot
about gaps that the dead space - one
where it's all kind of like sent really
hard into what the rules of that
universe are yeah and it makes it super
unique yeah the demons definitely take a
lot more to figure out because you're
like really figuring out like how
vulnerable you are what kind of well how
much your damage is doing what you can
do versus like when you're playing the
Slayer it's a more immediate like you're
just like oh this is just plays like the
campaign transferring that other guy
really carried me though because we
apparently won killing it first game
already in the bag heck yeah
Solid Snake wants know what we think of
the game I love it I think it's antastic
I also love it it took it took being
able to play with a keyboard and mouse
to make me like finally get it all I
can't I can't spider my hands on a
controller very well to do all the
buttons you need to do for this one but
keyboard and mouse just it's perfect
she's probably shuffle with different
people see one where I'm the Slayer if I
do it any better for that one heck yeah
ripping and tearing all day
if Persia was was streaming it uh
yesterday it was look like she's having
a good time
oh yeah I'm like nightmare is something
like that
I believe so which is a very bold move
that I haven't even attempted yet oh
they have the doot scan yeah you got
your dude skin going oh what I could
have been dude the whole time you could
have been Tooting it up man like the
beard thank you it's my quarantine beard
I've been
neglecting taking care of anything and
it's actually not doing too bad I'm kind
of India now looks good well thank you
wanna see it an eSports setting I would
actually really like like what does
high-level doom does high-level doom
look like that's a good question
I'm surprised not everyone is picking
Marauder all the time seeing as how
they've got a shotgun and also an axe I
found a few extra lives yeah I'm uh like
knowing the things that I know now for
my first playthrough doing my PC run is
just a breeze because I owe everything
is yeah some extra lives I've got like
five of them stacked before the end of
the first level like okay oh yeah that's
right you the switch version isn't out
yet which is real unfortunate they they
have like a like a small delay for it or
something but doom 64 is out on the
switch right now mm-hmm
I do kind of like the number the damage
numbers popping up because that gives
you kind of a good idea oh yeah yeah
let's see no the hit of it for sure but
as evil 3 demo was awesome can't wait
for the resistance open beta I'm
actually really excited to play the
resistance beta again John Luke and I
did a bit of the closed one yeah I I was
feeling it you see you seemed kind of
like you needed to see more of it or you
needed to kind of get more time with I
played a little more at a preview event
and I sort of feel about it the same way
I feel about this where I do think it's
cool but I question like the longevity
of it it's like there's like a
multiplayer thing like there you go easy
as that
there you go yeah I I'm really excited
to play the resistance
demo again and I I kind of skipped out
on the the three demo because like I
know that that game's gonna be good and
I know I'm gonna love it
hmm so I don't yeah okay I started to
download up three times yesterday trying
to figure out if I wanted to do it and
eventually was just like now download
okay there I mean bull for one I'm
pretty sure it's right because I saw at
that preview event I'm pretty sure it's
the same thing I played at that preview
event so I don't feel necessarily any
like need to you know it's also coming
out very soon it is second I can wait
just a little bit extra tips for beating
nightmare we've got we've got a video up
for that don't we we do we actually do
have a video up for that way if they've
played through nightmare I don't if he
finished nightmare but he played through
a good chunk of it and had some good
advice for it that seemed very useful
some some solid advice some cheesy
advice you want some cheese he's got you
covered
I'm always down for it there it is
Persia linked it up if you want I'll
forgive you for those nightmare tips but
you can watch that after you're done
hanging out here I mean watch it now but
make sure you come back but yes
yeah alright I'm I'm slaughtering a man
and slaying them we guys do a stream or
video on doom 64 we've done a couple of
videos on like the new level and stuff
yeah we put out a video that just shows
kind of like that new level they added
um it's a weird one because it's just
it's as doom 64 I don't have any
personal in the style for it cuz I never
played it so I played it and I'm like
yep this is uh old doom
that's for sure I appreciate that the
the included hit me to pre-order for
this though it's uh it was ported by
night dive studios I know if you're
familiar with them they're the guys who
ported they did Tarak they did System
Shock 1 in here and they're the one
they're the guys who are doing that
remake
of a system shock one so those guys
don't get enough appreciation like
they're really good at like porting and
getting to run like really old obscure
PC games and yeah so like I was like oh
like that kind of makes sense that they
got them to do like something like doom
64 that that feels in their wheelhouse
so shout-out to those guys for doing the
Lord's work
[Music]
Brandon Hernandez says so Animal
Crossing PD Friday next week yes
actually yeah it's the plan I think how
we want to do it is we'll just like open
up the we'll just give like a whatever
the friend code or something and be like
hey come come join our islands and hang
out come hang out with those yeah
because it'll give everyone some time to
kind of get acclimated maybe get some
things unlocked and they're there island
some cool clothes that they want to show
off yeah I I have cherries Ben you've
got pears
I've got pears and peaches I got peaches
this morning my mom sent me some peaches
my virtual mom not my real mom mm-hmm
this one
well the fun thing is because of our
setup if Ben wanted he could convert his
his webcam into just like an animal
crossing yep there it is yeah I was wait
honey you were just waiting for me to
mention it I was like this soon as
someone mentions animal crossing I'm
gonna get up I'm gonna do things Oh God
okay yeah yeah this is this is the it's
the ultimate game stream welcome to our
game stream you can't go wrong with this
how do you actually I think I've done
most of my things I need to do today
anyway I think I have to I was doing a
bunch earlier this morning well I've
been waiting for other stuff
work-related stuff come in yeah outside
of being a complete idiot in breaking
some of my Crocs that I need miss
chillin ah man I was doing really well
those first two rounds and I'm slipping
oh wow the cropping on the picture is
perfect to be able to see the the
talking to the talking it's not it's
pretty good oh yeah I don't I don't need
to I don't need to do I don't even do my
animal crossing thing I can I can keep
that off honestly I think that's fine I
think it's fine well I'll check in on it
every now and then
in my experience the super shotgun it's
just the way to go it really is it's
always like the ultimate way to go play
oh it's it's strong it's it's fast it's
it's got a grappling hook now uh what
the Demon Slayer sounds like if you turn
on classic sounds you'll actually get
his old like grunt whenever he jumps he
he does that and it's really good there
we go like whenever you try to like open
up a door or something and he just goes
oh yeah the classic sounds are excellent
I think did you have to preload
pre-order that for them it's it's either
a pre-order or a deluxe edition thing
either way I highly recommend I do not
know what just happened there you can
also turn on the classic like the
classic weapon position and it actually
adds animations for like the shotgun
whirls off the side and yeah Brax it
it's really good also I realized I can
do all this with my hand now it's really
good
it's a critical role doom eternal D&D
game holy cow I did not know that that
was really good
I'm going to check it out later action
oh no I got too eager actually I was
literally about to say what mondo said I
feel like in my mind doom Slayer sounds
like like Duke Nukem like just John st.
John doing whatever he does and if not
that then I imagined him sounding like
the new BJ blaskowitz cuz technically
from what everyone's put together the
doom Slayer is like a blaskowitz
descendant right
Oh is he is that the thing it's like
Commander Keen is like the grandfather
and then blaskowitz is the like dad and
then that's pretty - Slayers the kid or
something it's there's some weird like
all the Bethesda things are connected in
the weird way and apparently the doom
Slayer is supposed to be a blaskowitz oh
really that's fun yeah I'm really not
which explains kind of why their faces
are kind of like square and similar I
guess but not of players boo can't
believe this can't believe it
she's the beat hooker super shotgun for
cooking I'm into it um is anyone the
chat express interest in playing some
battle mode with us or oh I understand
anyone call it out yet but if you guys
do want to join the yeah it's down below
how you can get in you're playing on the
PC right now you could join up I set up
like I want the dude skin but then it
doesn't give me the dude skin it doesn't
do tit I'm not sure why well guess it
doesn't matter
Oh ruff what happen I just keep getting
booted keep saying there's not enough
players well in that case I think
whether it was looking for a slayer yeah
I love this game as battle theme music
it's awesome I love any time they bring
back BFG division because that's just
fanservice there there there are certain
times where it plays demon that's what I
want I tried the Marauder seemed
interesting he's got a shotgun and he's
got uh an axe what we going double
Marauder is that what we're doing oh
yeah stack it up can you play as a
premade duo of demons with another
player I don't think you play as a
premade duo but you can pick any one of
the sets yeah so like there's like
preset load outs and then I don't know
if you can customize the loadout so I
would assume so I admittedly haven't
like gone too far into like the
customization aspect of the multiplayer
will this have a VFR too only if they
try to make it a little bit better than
the last one yeah that was just kind of
okay I played like a couple hours of it
so no deathmatch no they've got this
this new three player battle mode thing
well just like is a unique concept I
think it's cool yeah I like the idea
behind it I do kind of miss deathmatch a
little bit I'm not gonna lie
okay so throw shotgun got it you just
get to be just like the ones in the
campaign and be super annoying annoying
and yeah just Wilin out here that is
definitely the demon class I would play
all the time
also uh you you like walked around a
corner and saw a demon and I was like ah
you've got to shoot that it's a bad yeah
no I'm not sure sure I'm not the same
thing it really messed with me and I'm
like oh wait a minute no that's not how
this works
so like you're not you're not too late
Oscar and we're just glad that you're
here no no no never too late yeah unless
it's like the last five minutes then
that's a whole shirt then you're maybe
too late but you're good
it is not the last five minutes so
you're fine you got em all right see
what other games have have we been
playing in our having to be locked away
experience uh some west of us
oh yeah yeah perfect topical game that's
good I've been meaning to like replay
that first one before for two so I'm I'm
excited and I'm still oh I like man I
think that first one holds up pretty
well like the in terms of the story and
like the the acting and the like the
wine delivery is like wolf that [ __ ]
still hits really well
game play not so much I'm not one of
those I've liked
the game's combat when it first came out
I wasn't on those people that like never
liked it but it definitely feels a
little finicky like a little little
glitchy at times like some of the
stealth stuff like I could just tell
like I would like to system isn't
perfect yeah yeah well it makes me
excited for two because I'm like cuz I
still like the idea of the game's combat
so yeah to improve upon it is like
exciting to me yeah I kind of want to
get another another run through that
whoo excuse me oh we got him we got him
we got him
heck yeah oh you can summon the dog
to get out of here some of those dog
this dogs freaking suck in the campaign
I've been playing PSO I've been playing
doom and now since last night Animal
Crossing so that's kind of where I've
been nice a lot a lot of PSO like I'm
I'm up to like 50 hours I think like I
gave a lot white lager wants to know
how's the new game mode and are we
enjoying it I like it I think it's fun
the it's more just like I don't know how
long of its gonna like laugh so I'm sort
of like I feel like I'm gonna kind of
get it while I can because I feel like
this isn't gonna be a thing that's gonna
be supported down the road it all
depends on if people engage in it right
like if it becomes really popular than
like they would probably support it but
I don't know though they like did a lot
of they did a lot of DLC for that
original teams multiplayer they did
you're right he did a ton so you kind of
wonder like it's possible they just
already have that stuff mapped out it's
like well we're working on it but the
fact that they're working on cam 2
campaigns also means like they kind of
know what people what people care about
this time oh we got him
Wow heck yeah is PSO no PSO isn't out
out but there's an open beta on the Xbox
right now mm-hmm
it's going for like two weeks but
apparently those characters carry over
to the other consoles when they come out
he was GameSpot beanies I I don't know
where these came from
I like my heart he pulled it out of a
box at some point threw it at me and was
like you like beanies wear this I don't
have that beanie I did go ahead and buy
that Tom Nook beanie though same Tom
Nook is a crook but that's a really nice
looking beanie
some people play in war zone Ritchie's
playing war zone nice
we got people playing Halo Reach heck
yeah
why not yeah if there's like any gains
that people want us to play with them
that they're like really into now it's
the time man now's the time to just do
that [ __ ] heck yeah I need to stop like
touching my beard don't touch your face
they say no exactly I know that's what
they keep telling me well I'm I'm in
quarantine yeah everything's controlled
at this point yeah you're fine you can
touch your own face the only thing
that's that's is the the wild-card
factor is this open window over here but
that's not how it works so you're fine
it's true unless someone came up and
like coughed into my window with like a
like climbing up on a ladder yeah we
should do some payday at some point
there's so much game to that game I've
never played it really now it's uh it
takes a lot of coordination it's got a
very very steep learning curve mm-hmm
but once you get it it's very very also
that game has one of the best
soundtracks in a video game in a weird
way you wouldn't expect it but wall to
wall bangers
okay these traps I have
I really wanna play too maternal yeah
it's it's a good time I'm actually I'm
actually kind of now that I got like
into the the PC playthrough I'm like
yeah I could just keep playing doom it's
pretty good pretty darn good I'm kind of
sad that there isn't like the arcade
mode at least that I could find it'll
add that I don't think the Arcade Mode
was out launched either in the original
yeah I think it might have been a post
launch thing too but I that's that's
what kept me playing literally until
like the week of eternal coming out was
the arcade mode we're playing together
we're not playing together we could play
together what this oh do you wanna do
you want to hop in and play some battle
mode with me I could I could try I could
try that I could give it a go good while
we do that yeah I don't know why it
didn't like occur to us yeah I don't
know why cuz I think we're just like
well we'll do what we normally do one of
those Lane the other will just you know
do their thing and I'm like wait a
minute we could just do it this way
yeah what is the invasion mode situation
what's up with that so I think they
maybe took it out cuz I tried looking it
up and the last I saw them talk about it
was that original thing like a year over
here ago like almost two years ago and
no one's mentioned it since so I'm like
I think they maybe took that invasion
thing out and that never got in the full
game because what what is in the game is
like if a player gets killed by a
powerful demons that demon will then pop
up in your game and what if that's what
it'll say like you're killed this person
no that's I know I think what it's
because it doesn't say you've been
invaded I don't know
I get the feeling that originally wanted
it to be what we thought it was and then
ended up not working out which is okay
but just kind of disappointing cuz I'm
sitting there being like oh man that
sounds great
I have booted the game you booted the
game up cool I'm on my way I wonder so
we'll connect to the online game
services Lobby than you just use why am
I not online their game servers have
been kind of weird
both those do net here invite you did my
party I will accept this when I can
hello what god yes a game I forgot
because my overlay is turned off what
exactly is happening okay I'm in I think
yeah you're my party heck yeah
oh I've got the music cranked so I
assume you're still in my party you are
okay returned the main menu I assume
you're still in my party now I do online
match is currently close to joining try
again in a few minutes it only lets me
pick demons because we have to be like a
a pair okay that's that's fine that
makes sense
however every time I do that the
matchmaking gets cancelled no I wouldn't
be surprised if it's if it's just you
know it's not working if it's just got
some issues and that's okay
tutorials loadouts triumphs get out of
here why is my revenant not the way it's
supposed to be I'll tell you why it's
cancelled
is there someone your end like not just
as searching for match and that's it I
need to mute myself because I'm probably
coming through twice for you no I'm not
no not for me
okay unable to find battle sick wait for
me turn off voice chat perfect can you
can you do like a like an AI Slayer we
just fight him that becomes that be
frightening also very cool get us in
I'll try this for another minute or two
but our cool plan might have to not work
out yeah that's right we gave it a go
you know yeah alright once your hop out
of mine my party meet you I'm booting
you from a party you don't that's fair
you've been kicked although I just came
family maybe it's time that bethesda met
stuff uh-huh no it's the Bethesda net
like not working gotten past the doom
hunter on nightmare that's some real
stuff do hunters are no joke it's the
Marauders man that's what gets me the
mouse the Marauders the Marauders are a
pain not just because they're difficult
to fight but because they go against the
whole idea of what Doom has been trying
to establish with the last two games and
that they're very much games about going
forward and tearing through things
without stopping where this whole enemy
is just designed to make you stop and
stare at it and wait for an opening yeah
and that's my only problem with it
anyway I'm gonna stop trying to think
about thoughts and think more about
Griffin a Terran no good
I don't know I feel about all these like
weird weekly challenge stuff they have
with this game yeah
I'm wondering how much that's tied and
he's sort of like are there more
cosmetics or unlockables and stuff well
because when I think of doom I don't
think of like Siri they call it like
series one like I'm like you don't need
like a battle pass
yeah the cause looks like a battle past
season setup yeah I'm like why like
you're not paying for it or anything
it's just like an incentive to keep you
playing more and I'm like okay that's
just so it's not like it's it's not like
a regular you pay for it or anything but
it's just sort of weird where I'm just
like what's the point
like I guess it's there for the
multiplayer because like it definitely
doesn't but like it also engages with
the single-player like when you get a
level in single-player you like unlock
stuff the arc vial is a hell of a thing
definitely maybe I would imagine to be
one of the truly asterick ters to play
in this oh I would imagine so
I definitely wanna try them yeah because
their whole thing is just putting up
shields and summoning things
oh that D was just kind of standing
there those arcade sound effects are
just I mean yet that's that's it he's
the troll e estas he can do what he
needs to do
John why it's my dude afk you might be
dude no what are you doing staring at
that wall pretty well oh and then he
left
does it go to 1v1 or does it does it
call off the match now oh god I are you
do you find a new hidden mode in battle
mode it's just what have you won
everyone I'm gonna lose though yeah is
kind of stacked against you
yeah it's 1v1 now let's go man
I could definitely win this sure you
can't see the skins in the cutscenes oh
you can yeah yeah that's kind of cool
which third I'd almost say for your
first playthrough as a heads up from a
person who's finished the game maybe
hold off on changing your skin to
outfits otherwise it might ruin a cool
story surprise for ya that's just that's
my personal tip to you you can have that
one for free you don't have to follow it
but it's my kind of like cuz i botched
it for myself and I don't want to see it
happening
dude way mine you just attacking me
that's cuz he has low health uh-huh
Wow you've got you got to do Slayer on
the run I killed him there you go just
like that
1v1 just like it done I'm I'm prepared
for you to take this whole thing I
appreciate it
should play with the original skin the
the default one is what I'd recommend
for your first I would as well
want the last boss to be Isabel I'd be
pretty good to get to Slayer in smash
let what do Slayer and Isabel hang out
for real no he's coming at you like
ready for it this because he knows it's
like I don't know what he was doing last
time like this time it's like oh yeah if
I just kill him I win it's like yeah man
you have the advantage
she's just so nervous
Oh team he'll excellent that'll be very
useful I guess I'm gonna Baron or
something oh hell yeah someone a baron
I'm kind of upset that you can't play as
parents they're kind of like one of the
coolest enemies in doom do Master Chief
and smash would be really cool too but
the thing is if you add Master Chief you
couldn't have Doom Slayer because
they're basically the same guy almost
one has just got a worse attitude than
the other
but I'm still holding out hope for for
Travis touchdown that's that's the last
like dream character I can think of that
I'll never get Francis York Morgan so
I'm not gonna ever like Dante Dante
would be cool but I'm not like itching
for it I feel like we have a really good
Dante in a fighting game that's true you
know at the Marvel games so I'm not I'm
not like oh man what would dad say be
like in a fighting game that's true that
is very true
I'd like I got him yo maybe one V ones
are the ultimate way to play this game
maybe oh boy there's all-stars
that's awesome thing put Duke Nukem in
Smash yeah there you go
that's the chat doing been super good
we're all just talking about smash
characters hit cap just hang out Vincent
Valentine it's smash why not alright
that's cool
Deadpool he he'd be an interesting
choice like he's kind of the same thing
as not saying though where I've seen him
in a fighting game already some kind of
yeah to be would be a very good
character to choose and she's also been
in Soul Calibur already mm-hmm
but to be nurses here as a 2d character
also to be is just good considering I
killed him twice I feel like I'm the one
I'm the real winner of that you you had
a lot of ads stylist just that makes
sense
put Jotaro Kujo and smash that again we
played a spawn yet and MK 11 I haven't
but I did download it I've got a chance
to try it out
alright spawns another what spawn was in
Soul Calibur so I'm kinda like it he
looks very very good at Mk
he also had he has this really cool move
in Soul Calibur that I do all the time
because it's just mm-hmm he'd take his
axe and then throw it up or brown behind
his back and then like catch it and come
down on someone on the other side it was
really cool I didn't know much about
that until the Xbox 360 version because
I was a GameCube player for it so I had
to link all the time
but it's cool that the redone HD version
of Soul Calibur 2 had both hi Hachi and
spawn in it
Oh Ben is Friday I know I'm really
excited to just spend the whole weekend
animal crossing crossing animals and
slang demons in between like this this
is a good weekend set up we've got two
very good games on two very opposite
ends of the spectrum and I just love it
it's exciting it's exciting times
it really is James I'm not allowed to
leave the house also a pretty cool thing
you know I missed the outside uh I feel
like this is my ideal this is like the
perfect setup for like persona 5 royal
because I was like man I don't know I'm
gonna have time to replay that again as
much as I want to now I'm like all right
man let's go watch time you know it like
joking aside I actually kind of really
like I'm enjoying being in one spot not
paying for public transportation so it's
weird I'm weirdly saving money because
I'm not doing I don't have to pay for
like the bus every day anymore it's it's
it's like you know like I don't have to
go anywhere I get to play games in the
comfort of like where I hang out my room
all the time
they're encouraging me to go and order
food from local businesses so it's like
takeout every other night not actually
anymore kind of slowed that up but
there's there's they're encouraging us
stuff it's just there's there's a lot
there's a lot going on right now
there is a lot going on right now
had five beers last night and discord
playing nothing but multiplayer campaign
rocks - heck yeah dude you want to play
some hats a flare somebody do it yeah a
pin show up on in I'd love to play with
somebody in the chat if they want a Oh
that'd be great we haven't done any any
beers yet unfortunately bud it's a real
good suggestion now I don't I don't have
any beer actually my I need to go to the
grocery store and pick up some stuff so
I know I don't have beer all I've got is
like rum oh so I've only got room for
rum rum just some rum room just some rum
room and I think I've got like wine
nothing nothing like that I can casually
just go for right I'm into it either way
can you join battle mode heck yeah you
can do join join up in the battle mode
if you guys do want to join the
instructions are down below basically
have to join the GameSpot group on Steam
because it makes it easier to find and
have people join yeah like it is easier
than like dealing with like friend
requests and stuff because you could
just do join me and then from there you
just join the chat and we can try to get
some people and maybe we can try to get
that together after this match if it's
only one person maybe if you joined we
can still do a private game we just
seemed like we couldn't get a yeah like
a quick game going if you go into
quarantine for two years you could take
either scam or fallout 4 what would you
choose
I feel like I could say Skyrim mophir
fallout just because I think Skyrim has
the bigger mod community has a pretty
big mod community as well I'm assuming
I'm a lot of mod [ __ ] yeah I'm also
assuming I'm allowed to mod stuff but I
think Skyrim's might be a little bit
bigger
possibly I'm debating if like an
apocalyptic quarantine if I want to play
an apocalyptic game the whole time or if
I rather play like that's a game that's
a good call - oh okay now I'm playing
like garbage it's actually a really good
point that makes me want to double up on
saying yeah okay sure get some people in
yeah sure I'll boot up my games just in
case only one of only one person is able
to get in but uh now we take it to the
next the next real one after Skyrim had
fallout how can we we ask the question
Skyrim or Dragon's Dogma that's that's
the real question
considerably less mods but whoo baby
that game is so good okay I sent you an
invite apparently Hugo recently said
that invasion was still going to be
added into eternal just not at launch
okay uh okay so they just they couldn't
they just couldn't get in an end time
they're still adding it that's exciting
then you don't maybe when they add that
well I'd like to make any Friday's I
think that'd be fun you in my party yeah
oh no not yet I am now also Bethesda net
let me connect this time around
yeah there we go okay home so I'll pick
Slayer you picked that and then hey can
I join
yeah dude-- yeah dude-- up are you able
to hear I'm curious if like this game
will work differently than this guy try
to join to her now that was never on I
was Friday I think if people were trying
to try to join I might have been kind of
wacky just cuz yeah I just say Jen when
I cook on your name
okay in that case let's just do it this
way then these jams they're good all
over the place so I'm gonna add him as a
friend in this case then and look for
there we go invite to party
heck yeah no I'll go straight forward
with a man cubist just for now just to
kind of like feel us now because this is
also this is my first time playing this
um I'm excited there we go we did it oh
we've done it we're all together I'm
gonna already up now I'm gonna be a
demonic flare heck yeah I like that the
the flames coming off of his gloves you
can actually like see them in your visor
it's really cool
although again I think it's just not
gonna show up it looks like you have to
like leave and then come back in and
then I like accepts it it's fine okay
hmm
let's do it
pretty great I feel pretty safe that you
can't really cheat like screen cheat at
this cuz the games just move so quickly
yeah right like it's just like I don't
know what benefit you would necessarily
gain from it this game you have online
that's what we're playing right now in
that online oh man it's I should turn
the music down at some point I can't go
back then to you as well I love this
like ESPN style like vs. yeah
transitional affect they are gone it's
real good alright alright
yeah
oh look where you going away from you
guys now do you see you should hang out
how do I spawn things in here that's the
question um middle stick or middle
middle mouse button oh I got it
okay okay yeah oh there we go there we
go there we go come on up oh Jesus
No there we go my pal Wow
uh-huh if I can just get you before you
free stones don't get me before he comes
back that's what I don't want no wait
came back just in time
that was a lot I stopped I stopped
breathing for like half a second dang it
you're gonna get back in here you betcha
I'm here
you blocked him elute heck yeah there we
go
come back here
oh [ __ ]
oh no yeah yeah
whoo there we go okay that's a good
second for us yeah no no no that was
like exactly what I wanted that was like
a really good back and forth and then we
got these things yeah yeah yeah
I've got a speed boost okay I'm starting
understand what I've got it takes a
minute the like I said the demons are
the tricky ones here we'll do a swap
after and I'll have you played the
Slayer I'm down for whatever this is I'm
cruising right now whoa Oh God that's a
good effort
go
need some help back
Oh God mmm well played Hank yeah those
look there's a lot to happen old one
whoo all right ooh that resource drained
I caught like half a second of the
monkey bars animation that's really
silly looking and I really like it oh no
boom you boy your boy botched it going
in way too hard
see ooh ooh
what all these always cool abilities did
he see what I picked I didn't uh but
I've got like I guess cuz if I were in
your situation I think I know what I
would pick
yeah
vulnerable get out of here I should have
a gun man I sure realize where I was
there's so much damage so fast I know
all day ammo just food dang it got the
sound design on all these these cat like
timer's counting down is
oh you guys got it all right
you're so fast and I'm so slow
hmm yeah bad I just got to get come on I
believe in my teammate in their ability
to survive he summoned a baron I
couldn't
oh hello
oh that sucked
god I got it I did the button oh that
timing damn dude you were standing still
and I was like you got me good
looks like I know what's happening [ __ ]
you might have you might have ended me
come on Oh where'd you told four - I
can't I can't see you oh I'm saved holy
[ __ ] yes yes yes oh yes I am
why do you guys have so many barons just
yeah you leave them up the the cooldown
resets oh god no no no no no no oh come
back no how did I not die you're so
close
oh okay this is I like this mode a lot
actually
I do too I realize I might have been
yelling into the microphone prop I
promised I'd yell at dead or alive
extreme when I yell so I wouldn't yell
into the mic ah that was good my end
[Laughter]
starts Kimberly enjoying it so far yeah
it's real good yeah yeah I like this
multiplayer again I don't know what
we've had the longevity of it or if it's
something I'm gonna be like oh I'm gonna
get really into it but for like just
playing right now I'm like I'm having a
good time I don't know yeah I think it's
worth playing a little bit like spend an
afternoon just have fun with it might as
well if you have the game already
compact your jean-luc where you going
there we go whoa
locking on
oh geez everyone's here the whole gang
don't worry I can take care of that oh
it doesn't kill him no oh yeah they're
they're immune to that aren't they are
they are the Barons of you into the the
V that seems cheap oh no I mean like the
the bigger things are well you guys are
I know you guys would be but I figured
you at least got the Barons off my chest
come on come on come on oh my god
oh no oh no I like the idea of the man
Kubis mantling something yeah that's
right oh then give me some armor no no
stay away from me burn for me no I'm
completely out of ammo oh my god oh that
was literally my last rocket hey welcome
back Oscar
okay here we go
this is intensive I would definitely
recommend playing this single-player
first just to light
yeah I love that flamethrower a lot baby
oh I'm done to give it a go unless the
whoever joined us would like to give it
a go see who we could we could try and
take him down
how do i back out of my spot o escape I
say in in the spirit of of the the title
of the stream I feel like they should be
the the doom Slayer from my knees
character hey when it's got
flamethrowers it's it's good charters
evil three online yeah we played a bit
of the closed beta a while ago tonight I
swear I'm gonna try in the arch file
because I think they'd be a good trolli
character the mess of them
only the projectile hurts players okay I
see oh I see what's happening that uh
that residual stream might actually
still be on this channel somewhere too
if you're interested in checking it out
all right
okay all right cool cool
that's so good as a senior I think your
volume got lower for me okay okay look
there you are it's my microphone issue
oh that's ones yeah that's what happened
with the podcast I love it yeah sure
well I'm gonna just hopefully that fixed
it but
like an idiot okay oh you can put though
you put the firewall way too high hello
I can do that thing where it's going
back and forth that's okay
so yeah I'm Mike might be finicky for
the rest of the stream but we'll
probably call this the last one anyway
we're almost that time I was gonna say
yeah I didn't realize how fast the time
had been flying by oh I really should
adjust my my game volume though it is
spicy
he's got like a vr teleport I like it
I just shot a demon Ike I'm in the
middle of doing this I still did it
oh here we go
Oh No I'm back
thank goodness cuz your boys about to
botch it oh you got some real cool
skills going on hey thanks for hanging
out thank you for hanging out Oscar
appreciate it looks cool sooo better
don't play online that's fair
it's just not not furred for everyone I
guess but man the single player is very
good
oh all right dad don't
I'm back hair here
I'm about to die
oh I'm out I'm cooked shoot
let's try to lock onto me Oh thinking I
can't go through that teleporting come
back five seconds
No Oh No dang oh shoot is Joey Joey how
you doing hey Joey
what's going on see how's it going dude
ooh check the science perk I'm ready to
bring it back this is it
the the first two rounds were a download
yeah
watching him like dash around it's so
funny yeah right
like oh that's what it looks like have
you seen the bar or the monkey bar
animation yet now it's maybe how I keep
my favorite one I'm an I'm peppering him
maybe we pick two demons that don't have
a very high damage output by themselves
like good compatibility yeah I kind of
worry about that
Calo good day
I keep shooting at the demons I'm too
used to it yeah it's definitely like a
weird mental thing I like shot at you a
couple times in there like first rounds
by a couple I mean a lot yeah see I just
did it right there
come back
you're running so fast oh yeah I feel
like our demon combo ism isn't the best
whoo oh boy nice I'm back
or looking kind of lower here zoms way
out I know I'm dead surprised people
remember not Joey you're you're killing
it in that cop head Oh something so I'm
just remembering cup head and three
round straight mm ow that was rough ah
man I still like I still like this a lot
oh it's fun you want to call here yeah
yeah we're we're close enough we're
right at the end my mic seems to be
working fine now but I mean I could do
one as the Slayer just to do it you know
why don't we do that why don't we do one
a supplier and if my mic guys again then
whatever we'll just we'll write it out
yeah all right I'm ready to just
faceplant
let's did you pick Slayer yes mm-hmm
okay
it's weird I don't know if it's doing on
your screen but like your guys names or
like not they're there so I'm like wait
who's who also tell it's because my low
level right I want to pick what does
this boost mean Oh speed up the rate at
which you learn cosmetic rewards oh you
can just boost people you could just
boost them I'm gonna give you a booster
you think yeah you've been boosted Peck
yeah four boosts for everything I don't
know what that means
did I just pay for that did my credit
card just get enjoy your $130 charge
that just happened to boost my phone's
gonna blow up and like my banks gonna be
like uh did you just spend $100 and do
maternal what are you doing yes like
[Music]
it's got off to work yourself heck yeah
Spencer ready to get your game in on
it's the weekend
baby I'm about to have me some fun Joey
if you're still in the chat you got
animal crossing I know you do
okay where are all my other guns
this is weird I keep hitting the old
super shotgun button price not finding
it it should be five that is it because
I think it used to be six yeah
oh my god I got got by a Cacodemons I
think yeah okay
all right fine this is good this is this
is a okay ready
well that dog mm-hmm that dog life
oh man yeah Oh awful it takes it takes a
minute like at that first the first time
I played this morning I got destroyed
all right round three I believe in you
Ben I against you but I believe in you I
think you tried it go in the teleporter
is a demon
we got here I'm definitely learning how
to be more tactical with the abilities
oh it got blocked that was me
damn so I want the run back on the
cetera played more on my computer well
I'm the person I'll run back you and me
we'll just yeah we'll do a whoopee one
again alright that was fun uh yeah that
was that was a lot of fun well awesome
god thank you for joining its pleasures
always God thank you thanks for playing
team eternal with us thank you everybody
who's been watching I hope that this
stream went okay without too many
hiccups seemed like there was a weird
thing with my mic but it corrected
itself which was great and yeah I mean
we're gonna keep streaming like this for
the foreseeable future until we're
eventually allowed to go back to the
office but it seems like we're able to
provide this if there's anything cool
you guys want us to stream or do let us
know I mean that's the time to like get
weird with it you know what I mean Ben
yeah let's just I'm telling you we gotta
play uh you know Shadowrun listen to
shuttering yeah that one guy at last
time we want to play Shadowrun well dig
shadow around but I think next week
we're gonna try and do some animal
crossing we'll probably just like set up
an open seeing and be like hey just come
join us